pretty cut out of our colors order arms
parade rest Phil Wiggins chaplain of the
national Fraternal Order of Police will
now deliver the invocation please remain
standing
please join me in prayer
our gracious father sitting before us
today or family members co-workers and
friends men and women in law enforcement
who made the ultimate sacrifice and some
seriously injured performing their
duties as we look out over these
families friends that are grieving and
hurting we ask the Holy Spirit moves to
please bring comfort and support and
strength and shield to those that mourn
today we claim the promise in your word
that that tells us that is no sorrow
today that you can't can't me and we
claim the promise in your word and there
is no sorrow so d you cannot sue their
father I know there are times we don't
sees the Sun but when we we know it's
there I know that behind the clouds the
face of God is looking upon us we pray
that you bring peace to these families
and peace to this great nation we pray
that you give us and they got our nation
and we will humble ourselves and pray
and seek your face and turn from our
wicked ways that you will hear from
heaven and forgive our sin and will heal
our land we pray for our nation national
leaders our president Donald Trump we
pray for him and his family for our
other national leaders gathered here
today we pray for wisdom and guidance
may you also continue to guide and give
wisdom to our national FOP president
Chuck Canterbury and FOP executive board
members as they continue to work toward
a better and safer law enforcement
across this great country watch over our
active men and women in law enforcement
and our military in your word he tells
us in Psalm 91 11 for he will command
his angels in regard to you to protect
and defend and guard you in all your
ways so we ask today for their
protection for our nation
what's your name we pray amen ladies and
gentlemen please remain standing for the
presentation of colors by the United
States Capitol Police ceremonial unit to
include the national anthem by Steve
McCall T and officer Kim Taveras from
the Boston Massachusetts Police
Department
standby colors outer guard Oh
ten colors right shoulder ours colors
ready Hut
colors outer guard present arms oh say
can you see by the dawn's early
what's so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and bright stars the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly streaming and
the Rockets red glare
[Applause]
[Music]
saved us or spangled
[Music]
the land although free
[Music]
colors right shoulder arms
ready cut
honor guard colors order arms
cartoons ready
you
you
you
colors outer guard parade rest please be
seated
my name is Chuck Canterbury national
president of the Fraternal Order of
Police and it's my honor and privilege
to welcome you the families of our
fallen heroes our law enforcement
community and all of the distinguished
guests to this 38th annual National
Peace Officers Memorial Service I'd like
to begin this morning by introducing our
guests who have joined me on the Dyess
for this solemn occasion beginning on my
right please welcome Mike Stanger the
Senate sergeant at arms and a longtime
FOP member thank you next to Mike is the
president of the concerns of police
survivors
Sheryl's schultz we're pleased to have
with us the acting architect of the
Capitol Christine Merton member of the
Capitol Police Board
please also help me welcome William I'm
sorry we'll Kenzel vice president for
governmental affairs for MillerCoors one
of our longest standing and most
generous corporate partners for this
event thank you for what you've done and
what MillerCoors has done for the law
enforcement community we're also very
grateful to have with us Laurie day the
acting executive director of the
National Law Enforcement Officers
Memorial Fund Laurie thank you it's an
honor to have with us today the chief of
our host agency Matt Verna Rosa of the
US Capitol Police who will be retiring
soon after 34 years in this organization
chief thank you very much I'm also very
pleased to introduce Phil Keith the
director of the office of community
oriented policing services the cop's
office is a keystone to our national
policing strategy from its hiring
program to the program helping officers
with mental health issues and mental
illness director Keith is able and ready
partner and we're grateful to have you
with us today Phil it's a very distinct
honor to be able to represent to you and
to you the majority leader of the US
House of Representatives Steny Hoyer who
is a longtime supporter of law
enforcement and has been to many many of
these services thank you it's also an
honor to be able to introduce the
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi who
has joined us today on the on the stage
thank you very much madam Speaker
it's my honor to introduce Linda Haney
the national president of the auxilary
who has hosted this service along with
the FOP for 38 years
I'll introduce Linda more fully in a few
minutes turning now to my far left
please welcome Paul Irving the Senate
sergeant at arms I'm sorry excuse me
sergeant at arms for the House of
Representatives thank you Paul
next we welcome mat Albert's acting
director for the US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement thank you very much
for being with us we're also very
pleased to have Donald Washington
director of the US Marshal Service thank
you sir for being here also joining us
today is the director James Murray of
the US Secret Service thank you sir for
being here we're honored to have with us
the acting director for the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco Firearms and Explosives
Regina Lombardo thank you
we're also very pleased to have with us
today the director of the Federal Bureau
of Investigation Chris Rea thank you sir
we're also very fortunate to have with
us again Kevin McHale Enon Acting
Secretary of Homeland Security thank you
sir he's been a guest at previous
services and I'm sure we'll see you here
again we're also very glad to welcome
back another longtime friend of the FOP
Labor Secretary Alex Acosta thank you
for coming it's also an honor to
introduce the Secretary of the US
Department of Transportation
Elaine L chow she's been with us at many
services and has actually delivered the
keynote for this service thank you very
much ma'am for being here
I'm also very grateful to welcome the US
Attorney General William Barr as our
nation's top cop we're very grateful to
have you with us here at this event and
finally it's a great honor and privilege
to introduce the president who I will
introduce more fully in a few moments
I'd now like to ask the Linda handy to
come to the podium for a few comments
mr. president members of Congress
brothers and sisters of law enforcement
family and friends of our fallen heroes
welcome to the 38th annual National
Peace Officers Memorial Service in 1962
President John F Kennedy proclaimed that
May 15th of each year be observed as
Peace Officers Memorial Day a day in
which to honor the brave law enforcement
officers who proudly wore the uniform
who daily served the communities in
which they lived and worked and who
ultimately made the supreme sacrifice in
the performance of their duties today we
honor 228 heroes of law enforcement
whose lives were taken in an instant or
who suffered debilitating diseases as a
result of working to save others their
deaths are of the same they served
steadfastly to protect the citizens of
our great nation these law enforcement
officers did not live for honors or pay
their happiness was in doing their job
protecting and serving the public on a
daily basis they knew that their job of
enforcing laws and preserving order in
the communities in which they lived and
worked made a difference but today is
not just about your fallen hero today is
about you your family your friends who
mourn your loved ones and the law and
the co-workers who often reminded of
your officer and members his or her
joking personality
their commitment to their partner and
their obligation and devotion to defend
the law they had sworn to uphold to you
those they leave behind
we offer our heartfelt devotion to
assure you that we will never let you
walk alone you and your family matter
you matter to your friends your family
in blue and you matter to us there is a
kinship a connection a bond like no
other between those that wear the badge
you need only to look around you today
to be reassured that your loved one will
forever be written on the heart and the
soul of the law enforcement community
Amy grace Taylor shares this inspiration
you may no longer see them with your
eyes but you will feel them in your
heart forever
these 228 brave men and women gave their
all they lay down their life to protect
and serve the families friends
co-workers and public who are here today
to honor them may they rest in peace may
God bless the families they leave behind
may God bless and protect the law
enforcement officers still serving our
citizens on the streets of this great
nation and may God bless the United
States of America thank you please join
me in welcoming reserve deputy Artie
Rodriguez of the Walton County Florida
sheriff's office who will perform if it
wasn't for the badge
[Applause]
[Music]
folded flag staying with tears they
remove the match from your chest god
this can't be real
now you won't compete in heaven long
gosh streets of when I take my last
breath
you'll be waiting at Heather
[Music]
stand still
assalam
moon stands alone a tribute to your
honor fallen brothers to
laughs taken out of anger for hatred of
[Music]
if it wasn't for the bad bad cops would
not play beautiful Amazing Grace as a
foe the flag and prey
you go would be saddling the rifles
would not drop
[Music]
if it wasn't for the badge
[Music]
cards on these one
this sacrifice swanny
it's not how they died it's half a day
if it wasn't for the badge the bad cops
would not play
[Music]
beautiful amazing grains as they fall
the flag
[Music]
you who would be sad
the rivals were not drawn
if it wasn't for the bad
[Music]
there would be no fire I know God called
you home and I miss you so bad
but I never would have met you if it
wasn't for the bag
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Artie
on behalf of the 346 thousand members of
the National FOP it's my honor to again
welcome you as we gather here to honor
our heroes it is with the memory of all
of those that we have gathered here each
May 15th to honor on this hallowed
ground the national Fraternal Order of
Police and our auxilary along with our
partners at the National Law Enforcement
Officers Memorial Foundation and from
the concerns of police survivors have
made the commitment to our families that
we will never let this country forget
the sacrifice that you the families of
our heroes have suffered and the
sacrifice the ultimate sacrifice made by
those heroes
these heroes were the thin blue line
that protects star protects our rights
and allows Americans to live peacefully
with fulfilling fulfilling lives the
American dream of life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness starts with those
who protect us from tyranny the vast
majority of our citizens understand that
security is the most important
responsibility of government but few
understand it like you do the inherent
dangers that our brothers and sisters
face each and every day
few understand the emotional toll on our
nation's peacekeepers and fewer still
have what it takes to perform the duties
of a law enforcement professional the
constant exposure to the worst of
humanity places a huge burden on our
nation's cops and the loss of one of our
officers affects each and every officer
as they pin on their badge or their star
and go to work as law enforcement
officers we pledge to go where others
run away and we do so not for honors or
praise but because we all feel the
responsibility to our fellow citizens we
take an oath of service and in doing so
we make that solemn promise to
render aid and keep our neighborhood
safe
that is not a responsibility that we
bear alone each and every American has a
responsibility to respect each other and
to make this country a beacon of freedom
we all have the duty to treat people
with respect and to support our great
nation today we honor those who made
that ultimate sacrifice we also come
here to make a pledge that we shall
maintain the memory of these heroes
forever hundreds of volunteers work
year-round to make sure that Police week
does what it is intended to do to
demonstrate to you the survivor families
and surviving law enforcement partners
that while we cannot fully understand
your grief or your loss we can do
everything we can to offer support love
and our desire for your loved one to
receive the appropriate respect from
their fellow citizens in 1985 President
Ronald Reagan and his annual message in
honor of Police week said let us resolve
to do all in our power citizens of these
United States to support our law
enforcement officers in their work and
pray that no more of them are taken from
their families and that they so Abele
serve in this way those who have laid
down their lives for their fellow man
will not have died in vain President
Reagan was right and I'm proud to say
that our current president Donald Trump
feels the exact same way and has done
his best to make sure that he thanks
every law enforcement officer that he
comes in contact with his police weak
messages have always been inspirational
and his speeches at this service have
always been received favorably by all
mr. president I thank you and I salute
you for your actions thank you sir
[Applause]
may God bless those officers working the
streets of America may God bless the
hundreds of police officers that are
protecting us on this site today and may
God bless this great country thank you
very much it's now my great honor to
welcome our keynote speaker mr.
president you were here with us on this
solemn day of remembrance for the fallen
that is a great privilege and honor to
have you here on this day our brothers
and sister officers their families and
loved ones come together to share our
grief and draw strength from the
knowledge that these sacrifices are not
made in vain and their memories live on
in all of us mr. president we welcome
you as part of this family and we thank
you for being with us here today and for
fighting for us every day in the Oval
Office the job of a law enforcement
officer has never been easy but mr.
president I have to tell you I think
it's getting harder our men and women in
blue are no longer seen as peace
officers who are there to serve and
protect instead we have become targets
of scorn and disrespect and all too
often of violence but mr. president you
have never wavered in your support your
strong commitment to keeping our nation
safe our communities safe and our
officers safe is deeply felt and we
could not be more grateful than to have
you with us here today and set that
example for all to follow mr. president
we hope soon to be sending you the
protect and serve Act which will impose
federal penalties on those who target or
ambush law enforcement officers the
House passed this bill one year ago and
we hope to pass it again soon in
pledging to protect and serve they
willingly place themselves in harm's way
but now harm is seeking them out and it
must stop and we know we can count on
you to be there for us and we could not
be more grateful and thank you for your
attendance at this service brothers and
sisters our survivor families
distinguished guests and all-americans
please welcome President Donald J Trump
President of the United States thank you
very much please thank you what a
beautiful day third time and I have to
say this is the most beautiful weather
so that brings us a little luck and it
brings us a little happiness Chuck I
want to thank you for the great job that
you've done your devotion has been
incredible I've known you a long time we
work together
and congratulations earlier doing a
fantastic job thank you very much thank
you as president I am deeply honored to
join in this sacred commemoration for
the third year in a row today in the
heart of our nation's capital we come
together to pay tribute to the American
Peace Officers who made supreme
sacrifice all in the line of duty in
many cases for people they never met for
people they didn't know we're here to
remember their noble lives to thank God
for their profound courage and to
express our love respect everlasting
gratitude for the heroes of law
enforcement and that's what they are and
were the heroes of law enforcement we're
pleased to be joined today by Attorney
General William Barr doing a great job
secretary Acosta secretary Chao and
acting secretary miquelina thanks also
to the members of Congress and
attendants of which there are many and
to the leaders of the Fraternal Order of
Police including Jim Pasco Linda Haney
and chaplain Wiggins to all of the
families of our fallen officers our
whole country is praying for you
embracing you and pledging to you that
we will never ever leave your side never
disappoint you your loved ones were
extraordinary and selfless Americans who
gave everything they had in defense of
our communities our children and our
nation these brave heroes did not put on
the uniform for praise or for glory they
wore the badge because it was their duty
they're calling their noble purpose to
serve protect like nobody has ever done
it before they embodied our highest
ideals and greatest aspirations they
were the very best of us there was
nobody close today we engrave their
memories into our hearts and inscribed
their names into the eternal roll-call
of American heroes in honor of the
Fallen we pledge to always support their
brothers and sisters in blue we stand
firmly strongly and proudly with the
incredible men and women of law
enforcement
you do not hear it nearly enough but
Americans across this country love you
they support you they respect you more
than you would ever know more than you
would frankly ever think even possible
they have great respect for law
enforcement and the job you do as we
memorialize those officers who fell in
the line of duty
we also grieve for the 87 officers who
died in recent years as a result of
exposure to toxic debris following the
terrorist attacks of September 11th 2001
I would like to ask all of the families
and fellow officers of those 9/11 heroes
to please stand thank you please thank
you very much I can tell you I live in
that city and lived in that city during
that time and the job they did was
incredible today we renew our solemn
oath that we will never forget before we
read the names of the Fallen I want to
share a few of the stories that
exemplify the courage of those we honor
at the ceremony last year America lost
two extraordinary officers from
Brookhaven Mississippi patrolman James
white and corporal Zak monk James asked
his mom to sign a waiver so he couldn't
list in the Army National Guard at the
age of only 17 nearly 18 years in the
military James became something that he
always wanted to be a police officer his
teammate Zack spent time caring for his
niece
and nephews and family on days when he
worked the night shift he would tell
them while you were sleeping I will
always be watching over you last
September James and Zach responded to a
report of shots fired at a home when
they arrived they bravely engaged the
shooters it was a bad two minutes it was
violent and it was vicious within
seconds the killer shot James at that
moment Zach could have raced to safety
instead he raced to the side of his
friend as Zach tried to save his
teammate he too was shot and killed
giving his life for his brother in blue
today we remember the words James once
told his mom he said mama if I ever die
in the line of duty know that I died
doing what I truly loved this morning we
are honored to be joined by the families
of both of these remarkable officers -
patrolman James White's mom Laurie and
dad Daryl and sons JC and James and to
corporal Zach bokes mom Vicki dead
marshal and brother Chris your heroes
loved their job they loved their country
and today their love shines down on you
from heaven they're watching right now
they're watching they're looking down on
you and they're proud so please could I
have you just stand up the families
please please
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
two great men also here with us for this
ceremony or the families of investigator
Farah Turner and Sergeant Terrence
caraway of the Florence Police
Department in the great state of South
Carolina
last October investigator Farrah Turner
went to the house of a man suspected of
a crime against a minor when she and her
fellow officers approached a gunman
opened fire from his second-story window
nobody knew it could happen nobody
thought it was even possible there was
no evidence no anything but they knew it
was trouble at that very moment Florence
police sergeant Terrence caraway a very
popular person in that whole area of
South Carolina they all knew him
legendary guy he was on his way home he
heard the call come over the radio he
sped to the scene jumped out of his car
and was racing to the rescue
he knew the bullets were coming but he
kept going forward and he was struck by
one of those bullets in total seven
officers were shot on that very terrible
day we lost
sergeant caraway a 30-year veteran of
the department as his pastor has said he
wore a badge of love and every time you
were in his presence you could feel that
love that's what they all say
investigator Farrah Turner was also
fatally wounded she passed away several
weeks later in her final days hundreds
of members of the community came to
at her in the hospital they loved her
they spoke of the way she not only saved
them from danger but changed their lives
through her grace her support and her
prayers to investigator Turner's mom
Katie and sister April and - sergeant
Carraway's wife Alison and son Terence
brother Daniel and sisters cinavia and
negocio your loved ones died today it
was a sad day but they're looking down
on you now they died as they lived
fighting to protect innocent people we
will always remember them we will always
profoundly be grateful to have with us
two of the surviving Florence officers
who were shot that October evening Brian
Hart and Travis Scott Brian and Travis
your continued service honors the legacy
of your great friends thank you for
being with us please stand
thank you very much thank you for being
here the ambushes and attacks in our
police must end and they must end right
now we believe that criminals who murder
police officers should immediately with
trial get the death penalty but quickly
the trial should go fast gotta be fair
but it's got to go fast
[Applause]
and that's happening fair but fast right
fair but fast in the year before I took
office the number of officers killed in
ambushes rose to the highest level in
nearly 30 years in the last two years
thankfully the number of officers killed
in ambushes has decreased by more than
70% I'm very proud to have sent to all
of the police departments all over the
country hundreds of millions and even
billions of dollars worth of military
equipment that wasn't being used
beautiful wonderful safe great equipment
that wasn't being used and other
administration's didn't want to send it
some day you'll explain that one to me
but it's been sent and it's been used
and I've had so many people tell me how
happy they were and how many lives are
saved we'll never back down when it
comes to protecting our police ever ever
in my administration we strongly condemn
hateful anti-police rhetoric and you're
hearing it you're hearing it we don't
understand it we don't think it's even
possible that they can think or feel
this way but there are some people out
there that do in recent years another
dangerous trend has begun a number of
prosecutors in cities such as
Philadelphia and Chicago have decided
not to prosecute many criminals who pose
a severe threat to public safety and
community well-being every prosecutor
takes an oath to uphold the law not to
advance a political agenda
last year in Philadelphia robbers shot
and gravely injured a deli owner he was
a good man he'll never be the same but
he may serve this criminal a sentence
that is very short in fact they're
looking at about three years if you can
believe this three years dangerous
criminals must be punished to the
fullest extent of the law
that's the only language they understand
and those who file false police reports
should face full legal consequences
every American child deserves to grow up
in a community that's secure and safe
from violence and free of fear here with
us today is the family of California
police officer Ronelle Singh and I've
got to know his family they're an
incredible family they just left the
Oval Office we took pictures and it's
not an easy situation what they're going
through frankly they're going through
hell where Arnold came to this country
legally in 2003 with the dream of
earning the badge of an American police
officer that was always his dream and
that's exactly what Rael did he devoted
his life to defending the laws of our
country on Christmas night he took a
picture in front of the family Christmas
tree with his beautiful wife
they beloved son and Sam they're loyal
police dog it's a picture that all of us
saw
I remember it so vividly I'll never
forget it I didn't know I'd get to know
the family and greet the family and show
the family the Lincoln Bedroom at the
White House I didn't know that but it's
an extraordinary family but I'll never
forget the picture then corporal Singh
headed out on duty which he loved to
protect and to serve you all know the
story because hours later he was gunned
down and killed during a simple traffic
stop he was a vicious killer this man
that crossed into our country from the
border just a little while before a
vicious killer that could have been kept
out with border security with the wall
with whatever the hell it takes could
have been kept out but we're getting it
there we're building the wall we're
beefing up like you wouldn't believe the
military is come into action people are
trying to come into our country
illegally because our country is doing
well they can't come in illegally they
have to come in through the legal system
they have to come in through merit they
can't come in like this killer came in
just rode across the border went through
every sign he could go through but the
family is special
Ronelle was special and today we're
really grateful to be joined by corporal
Singh's wife Anamika
and their precious ten month old son are
now where are usually right here
someplace stand up please them and also
here are his great parents Ronnie and
veer
and his brother where is Reggie his
brother Reggie what a great family
Reggie come up here will you please come
on up come on this is unexpected but
this family I tell you you know you get
to know some people come on up they may
let you up I think so I think Reggie's
okay come on up Reggie how about
bringing a beautiful boy up come on up
come on mrs. Singh come up come on up
you know what how about mom and dad -
come on up mom and dad wife and baby
come on up come
it's incredible family that's great
gotta see it to understand what it's all
about it's hard to imagine what they've
been through hard to imagine
come on up reg you didn't know you'd be
doing this Reggie sorry Reggie
I am the brother of Coronel saying I'd
like to thank every single law
enforcement officer over here what do
you guys go through I heard stories from
my brother this man over here the same
family supports him whatever he's doing
for the law enforcement we support him
his team at the White House has reached
out to us multiple times multiple times
I don't think that has ever happened
before
ever this man is amazing and my family
supports him thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much folks thank you she
said no no I don't want to speak
actually I do
it's something I didn't get to do with
the office I actually want to thank you
personally for you're the only one that
actually reached out and said gave you
condolence to the family and it actually
means a lot to all of our law
enforcement bodies that are here for the
sacrifice my husband thank you very much
so beautiful such a beautiful family and
there will be justice justice will
happen we have the people and we have
the spirit we have the mindset which
taking care of our law enforcement
officers and we're taking care of
everybody but we cannot imagine your
pain I mean doing that just doing that
Reggie thank you very much fathom what
you've been through but we pledge to you
the unwavering love and support and
devotion of this entire nation we have a
great nation and it's getting better and
better every day it's getting stronger
we're not relying on outside forces and
outside countries that don't really care
about us other than to take advantage of
our people and our system and our nation
is strong again and getting stronger
every single minute
joining the sings are more than 10 other
family members and close friends along
with 22 of his fellow officers please
stand would you please stand 22 officers
thank you so was he as great as they say
he was he was I had a feeling you might
say that he was that's what I hear from
everybody good thank you very much for
being here we appreciate it you remind
us all that when our heroes fall our
community stand together as one they get
stronger we'll always remember corporal
Singh as a hero and a truly great
American not one more American life
should be lost because our lawmakers
fail to secure our borders tremendous
problems of course at the southern
border from drugs to the wrong people
being allowed to come in because of a
corrupt and broken system that can be
changed in 20 minutes 20 minutes if they
want to change it in the meantime we
have to do it the tough way and there's
no reason for that
that's why we are calling on Congress to
fix our terrible immigration laws stop
catch and release you catch him and you
release him that doesn't work too well
with all these great offices I'm looking
at they never heard of a thing like that
to end deadly sanctuary cities to stop
the Visa Lottery program where they take
lottery systems and a country will put
you into a lottery and then deposit you
into the United States I don't think
most countries are giving us their
finest we agree and that's what's
happening and it's causing tremendous
problems with crime and other things and
I have to tell you border patrol and ice
and just law enforcement
in general the job they've done and the
job they're doing is incredible what
they have to go through the bravery I've
gotten to know so many especially at the
border and what they have to go through
and the danger is incredible but they do
it and to them it's something they love
to do they feel they're doing it for
their country they love to do it and
they do it well to every mom and dad
brother and sister spouse and child of
the brave fallen officers we honor today
America joins together in expressing our
love and our gratitude our grief and our
firm resolve to be with you every single
step of the way we will never let you
down your loved ones were the finest and
the bravest and they're all looking down
right now they're looking down on their
families every time they put on the
badge they knew they might not make it
home and so did their families know that
each time they went on a shift they knew
it could be their very last and when
that can time came where they knew there
was danger when evil lurked they did not
run they did not hide they always ran
forward they answered the call they gave
their lives for all of us the men and
women of law enforcement devote their
lives to protecting our children
securing our streets and keeping our
community safe
moms and dads can sleep soundly at night
kids can play with neighbors outside and
grandparents can feel at peace in their
homes because they know America's
officers are the absolute best and
they're always on the beat the courage
and sacrifice of our heroes is the
reason our flag stands tall and bravely
our hearts beat with pride and our
country remains one people one family
and one nation under God
today we thank you we honor you and we
forever cherish the memory of our fallen
men and women in blue you have very
special people there nobody like you
nobody god bless you god bless our law
enforcement
god bless the Fallen and God bless the
United States of America thank you very
much thank you
thank you
[Applause]
you